what is up everybody it's 414 anime here
for anime oprah and today i will be
breaking down and explaining every
bonkai in bleach now with bleach's hype
anime return on its way we thought it
was about time to start putting out some
videos on this awesome series and we are
so excited about it so make sure to let
us know in the comment section below
what bleach topics and videos you would
like to see us cover over on the channel
now if you do enjoy these bleach videos
on the channel and you'd like to see
more you know what to do smash that like
button get suga tensho style if you
haven't already make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications you
can also follow us on twitter and
instagram at animeoperal and now without
further ado let's jump into this
spoilers and all bankai which means
final release is the second and final
upgraded form of a soul reaper's zompoc
toe after shikai which is the first
upgraded form of the zampocto after its
initial sealed form the bangkai form has
overwhelming power which is far beyond
that of a normal weapon now to achieve
this evolved zompot toe a shinigami must
be able to defeat and materialize their
zombocto spirit into the physical world
this process has been said to take 10
years or more to achieve as well as
having the experience needed in order to
master it and you know is one that very
very few soul reapers have ever been
able to achieve the exception would be
both ichigo and urahara who reached
bonkai in a much shorter time three days
to be precise though the method that
they used was also much more dangerous
the two used a special device that was
created by urahara the genius himself
now this device forced the zampato
spirit materialize which bypassed a
large part of bangkai's training which
was the spirit's manifestation urohara
tested his device and achieved bankai
but stated that using this method for
more than three consecutive days would
prove to be fatal which put a lot more
pressure on each goat to achieve it now
back to bangkai bonkai is up to 10 times
greater than its shikai form it is the
ultimate technique of the zampakto the
form as well as its power will solely
depend on the zompocto itself as well as
the wielder's own strength and training
and even though bankai is the final
stage of a zampakto it can still grow
and become stronger the more the spirit
recognizes its wilder the stronger it
will be if the zombocto does not fully
recognize its wilder it may choose to
withhold its bonkai's true name which
would mean that the zombocto wouldn't
take its true form in bonkai and of
course would be a lot weaker so let's
start looking into every bangkai
starting with series protagonist and
substitute soul reaper ichigo kurosaki
ichiko's zampakto is zangetsu and his
bankai is called tenza sangetsu which is
translated to heaven chain slaying moon
we first saw his bonkai in his fight
against biakya in the soul society now
the original tenza zangetsu gave ichigo
a significant boost in both speed and
power allowing him to pull off a much
more powerful black get sugar tent show
blast as well as that the cloak that
ichigo wears in this form is a visual
representation of his own spiritual
power as this cloak is torn and shred
throughout battle it is a visual
representation as i said of each ghost
power weakening now compared to the
other bonkai in this video ichigo's
original bankai isn't really as
elaborate as the others however it is
one that is largely a mystery at this
point and even now we still don't really
know exactly what his true bonkai does
because the information hasn't been
revealed to us just yet and of course
each goes bankai has undergone some
changes throughout the series after
ichigo lost his powers using mugetsu
against eisen ginjo taught ichigo how to
use full bring powers using this and his
bankai the sword took on a different
appearance from the black katana of his
original the sword was curved and had
perforations which looked pretty awesome
to be honest later on each girl learns
his true lineage as well as eisen's plan
and gets his real zampogto which are
dual swords now to activate his bonkai
each go places the two blades of his
chicai together creating a surge of
energy around him and the swords like i
mentioned the power of ichigo's true
tenza zengetsu is currently unknown but
we do know that he is considered
extremely dangerous we also know that he
can fire an enhanced getsuga tent show
that is much more powerful than a normal
one and is also gold in colour however
unfortunately that is all we know for
now hopefully if the manga decides to
pick up again we will learn more but for
now the only one who knows the power of
ichigo's true tenza zengetsu is none
other than kubo himself
next up we have the captain of the first
division and head captain of the 13
court card squads genry yusai yamamoto
his zompokto is called ryojin jakka and
his bankai is zanka notachi which means
longsword of the remnant flame or blaze
of ember according to the viz
translation now when yamamoto activates
his bankai the blade takes the form of
an old worn out katana that looks to
have been scorched by fire any flames
that have been produced by riyan jakka
are instantly absorbed into this blade
and will burn anything that it cuts out
of existence completely because of its
overwhelming power the moisture of
everything around it including the air
itself is completely dried up yamamoto
himself has claimed that the release of
his bonkai coats both himself and his
blade in the flames of the sun itself
yamamoto's bonkai is of course a fire
type and arguably the strongest in the
entire series and it is split into four
insane parts being zanka notachi east
west south and north zanka notachi east
rising sun edge is automatically
activated upon the bangkai's release and
its ability focuses all of the intense
flames to the very tip of the sword
these flames do not burn the enemy but
instead incinerate them into complete
nothingness zonka notachi west remnant
sun prison garb again is activated
automatically upon the release of his
bankai yamamoto's body is completely
engulfed in heat which reaches
temperatures of 15 million degrees as
you would expect it is impossible to
touch him or even get close to him while
his bonkai is activated this ability is
just absolutely insane as the heat from
this ability is that high that it
doesn't take on an appearance of flames
in fact they are completely invisible to
the eyes of his opponent unless yamamoto
himself wishes for them to see it if you
didn't think yamamoto could get any more
insane zanka notachi south great burial
ranks of the 10 trillion fired dead
calls upon and summons the corpses of
the ones who were killed by his flames
in order to fight for him now yamamoto
will impale the ground with his sword
and using the heat from it on their
ashes the dead appear like burning
skeletons from the very cracks in the
ground that he had just made who will
attack his enemies until they return to
dust yamamoto can also call forth
specific corpses if he so wishes
finally there is zanka no tatchi north
heaven and earth end in ashes this is a
large and very powerful slash of heat
and flames that just incinerates
everything that it touches completely
out of existence now due to the absolute
extreme heat that radiates from both the
blade and yamamoto himself there is a
time limit on his bank eye he can only
wield zanka no touchy for a short amount
of time otherwise prolonged use of his
bankai will destroy his opponent the
area around him or even himself
omanyama is just an absolute beast and i
love his bonkai again this one is
arguably the strongest in the entire
series and it is very very easy to see
why chojiro sasakibe was the former
lieutenant of the first division under
head captain genryusai yamamoto where he
held this post for 110 years chojiro
zampokto was called gon ryomaru and his
bonkai was coco gomrio rihu translated
as yellow glittering royal villa of the
stern spirit or simply golden lightning
palace as the viz translation puts it
chojiro's bonkai is a lightning type
that will produce a bolt of lightning
from his blade which he then transforms
into a dome of lightning high above his
head that is hooked down by a large
number of lightning pillars there is
also a singular pillar of lightning that
comes from the dome and reaches towards
the sky these pillars of lightning
chojiro can use and manipulate at will
of course due to its element chojiro's
bonkai is more than capable of affecting
the weather just like hits a guy is that
we will cover a little bit later
not only can it generate thunder and
lightning storms but it can also summon
large dark clouds that enhance the power
of said lightning just as the lightning
pillars chojiro can launch powerful
lightning bolts from the sky at his
enemy by using simple hand gestures
soy phone is the commander in chief of
the stealth force as well as the captain
of the second division her zampakto is
called suzumabachi and her bankai is
ho reichobin translated as hornet
thunder duke whip her bonkai takes the
form of a giant golden missile its base
completely engulfs her right arm all the
way above her shoulder that forms a face
shield covering the right side of her
face the missile itself is absolutely
huge in fact it is twice the size of soy
phone herself who stands at 4 foot 11
meaning that this golden missile is
approximately 9 foot 10 inches
soy phones bonkai is a range type and
she has the ability to launch the huge
missile from its base at her target she
raises her right arm and uses the slit
in the face guard to line up her shot
once the target is locked on the missile
tracks said target with precision on
contact the missile creates an
incredible explosion there are downsides
to her bonkai in the fact that she has
stated that she can only fire one
missile every three days
anything more than that is extremely
taxing on her own body and the recoil
from the shot is also very explosive and
sends soy phone herself flying soy phone
uses her bonkai so rarely that it hasn't
been seen by most in the soul society
even her lieutenant has claimed to have
never seen it the reason being is you
know of course one how taxing it is to
use and two the fact that soy phone
prefers not to use it as it damages her
pride as the commander of the stealth
force it is a weapon that is just way
too big to hide and its flashy nature
goes against that of assassination
gene ichimaru was the former captain of
the third division until he betrayed the
soul society along with both sosuke
eisen and conor may tozen geen zampakto
is called shinso and his bankai is
kamishi niyari translated to mean god
killing spear in its bankai form his
zompoc toe does not change in appearance
his bonkai's abilities are you know also
pretty much the same as his chic eye in
which the blade glows a bright white
colour and extends at very high speeds
with a great force that will impale his
targets however when his bonkai is
activated the force speed and length of
his blade are all vastly improved so
much so that king could cut an entire
town in half while standing at quite a
distance from it if he so wished now in
terms of numbers gene claimed that his
sword could extend up to 8.1 miles at
500 times the speed of sound which means
that his sword would have been able to
extend 171
500 meters in under 0.08
seconds which is just absolutely insane
however this was later revealed to be a
lie to gain the advantage in battle by
unnerving his opponent the true and
deadliest ability of his bonkai is that
while it is expanding for a split second
the blade itself turns to dust there is
a deadly poison within that blade that
can dissolve and break down cells gene
will leave a tiny part of his zompoc toe
inside the body of his opponent when he
retracts his blade which allows him to
kill his target at any time that he
wishes to do this gene will place his
hand on the target and utter the
technique's name of korres a kamishini
no yari causing the person to break down
from the inside out absolutely love
genes bangkai and i think it really does
go well with his character big props to
my guy keen what a legend
next up is shusuke armagai he is from an
anime anime-only arc and you know what i
really enjoyed this guy's character i
thought he was rad and would i
definitely would have loved to have seen
more of him but you know so he was
another former captain of the third
division succeeding geen ichimaru
amigai's zampakto was called riker and
his bonkai was rika gohinkaku which when
translated means lightning flash karmic
flame shell his bankai was a fire type
and when activated his zompokto took the
appearance of a large and more detailed
version of itself than when it was in
its shiikai form it is a large crimson
red sword with jagged edges and a hook
at the end it also had a large white
shell covering the hilt and the sword
was about as tall as amagai himself
unfortunately there is no exact height
for i'm a guy but he was a pretty big
dude so yeah the sword was a beast so
when his bankai is activated fire
surrounds the sword and he can use a
host of abilities that involve said
element including using it as a
flamethrower it can shoot enhanced
fireballs armor guy can generate fire
from the ground when he pierces it with
his zambok toe it could create waves of
fire and so on he also has the ability
go in ryuga where amagai will twist and
spin the sword above his head the blade
is completely engulfed in fire and
flames and will shoot out of it he will
then slam his zompakto into the ground
along with a lightning strike and as the
ground itself begins to shake fire
spears will also shoot from the ground
at various angles trapping his enemies
within this one is like one of those
super combo moves and as you can imagine
this technique takes a lot out of him
again definitely an interesting
character and i did enjoy his bonkai but
when it comes to fire there is only one
king here
rojiro otarobashi more commonly referred
to as simply rose is the captain of the
third division
his zombocto is called kinshara and his
bankai is kinshara bhutadan translated
to mean golden sal tree dancing trope or
by viz's translation golden sharla dan's
trope when his bonkai is activated a
giant pair of golden floating hands
appear one of them holding a conducting
baton as well as that several large
golden freaky looking beings also appear
that are known as the dancers of death
pretty rad name and it definitely
definitely suits their appearance that's
for sure so rose's bonkai is like that
of a play using music he can create
physical illusions with rose himself
stating that music gives him power over
his target's heart as long as their
heart is deceived which is a pretty
powerful statement right these illusions
are no joke they are realistic and can
even afflict powerful physical damage to
his opponents not only that but they can
affect their surroundings and rose
himself again has claimed that his
illusions can stop an opponent from
breathing altogether pretty pretty uh
breathtaking stuff right
sorry the way his bonkai works is by
manipulating his opponent's sense of
sound tricking them into believing that
physical pain is being endured the
attacks that rose can perform are like
that of a play where the dancers of
death follow acts and by using the baton
rose acts as the conductor to said play
so act one is c drift where the dancers
of death surround his opponent and spin
around creating a whirlpool of water
this makes the target feel as if they
are drowning the second act is
prometheus rose conducts the dancers to
generate fire with their hands the
effect of this illusion makes his target
feel as if they were being burned alive
the final act i may pronounce no i will
pronounce wrong it's called ein
heldenlaban which is german for a hero's
life now unfortunately this one was
never seen because he was taken out
before he got the chance to use it
cool name though
retsu una hana was the former captain of
the fourth division she was one of the
oldest captains among the soul society
and was their best healer she was also
the first person to hold the name
kampachi
yeah so her zompoc toe was called
minazuki and her bankai was of the same
name though their translations were
different her zampok toe when translated
means flesh dropped gorge and her bonkai
when translated means all things end
which is a very very intense and very
awesome name what they both are now when
her bonkai is released the blade of her
zompoc toe turns into a thick dark red
liquid that flows all around her which
many have theorized is blood but there
is no no confirmation of that the liquid
of her bonkai is that of a very strong
acid strong enough to melt an opponent
to the very bone unfortunately there
isn't a lot known about her bonkai as
she was killed before we could really
see what it was capable of but from what
we do know as well as its name it is a
very very nasty one that you would not
want to come up against
next up we have one of my favorite
characters biakya kuchki he is the 28th
head of the kuchiki clan one of the four
great noble clans in the seoul society
and is also the captain of the sixth
division biakyo's zompokto is called
zenbon zakura and his bankai is zembon
zakura kagayoshi which when translated
means vibrant display of a thousand
cherry blossoms it's beautiful isn't it
very very beautiful his bankai is a
larger version or an extension of his
shika i guess you could say where
instead of being able to create one
thousand flower petals in its shikai
form zenborn zakura kageyoshi creates
millions biokyo drops his zompocto into
the ground which then goes into the
ground in a puddle of water and energy
ripples throughout turning the
surrounding area dark two rows of giant
swords rise from the ground no one knows
just how many swords have risen and they
scatter countless blades then strike his
enemies these blades unlike his chicai
can be controlled using his mind and
further enhanced if he decides to use
his hands to direct their motion his
bankai can be used for both offense and
defense and have several forms and
abilities he can use in battle each of
these abilities create different
advantages depending on his situation
making zembon zakura kagayoshi one of
the most versatile bonkai he has the
ability senki or slaughterscope when
translated which is the true form of
zenbon zakura the scattered petals form
into thousands of glowing swords that
circle around biakya and his opponent in
rose moving in a circular motion this
actually turns his thousands of blades
into fewer but more powerful swords that
are much much stronger in their attack
power beyokyo can control these swords
mentally but often prefers to wield them
physically now though this is the true
form of zembon zakura this ability is
one that is extremely rare for him to
ever use biokyo will only ever use this
ability if he has personally swore to
take down his opponent with his own two
hands that's in the fact that this
ability also requires bjorkya's own
bullet to activate which could be
another reason as to why he doesn't want
to use it all that much it makes sense
i'm not for that sticking with this
ability he has a sub ability within it
called ika senjinko where he will attack
a single target with every one of his
senki swords at once this is zembon
zakura kagiyoshi's ultimate attack
another of his abilities is called goki
which is a sphere of tiny petal blades
which will swirl around his opponent
like that of a cloud not one angle is
left uncovered by these petals meaning
there is not only no blind spots but
there is also no escape for that target
the sphere then collapses within itself
destroying the poor being trapped within
the last ability is called shuke
hakutaiken this ability takes all of the
thousands of petals and compresses them
into one giant sword which boosts its
power considerably the blade takes on
the appearance of a bright white bird a
halo circle appears at biakia's back
made of spiritual energy and the strike
is a final final finishing blow it's
it's gnarly i love that one
renji abbarai is the lieutenant of the
sixth division under his captain
biakyakuchiki he also previously served
as the sixth seat of the eleventh
division under kampachis of rocky prior
to becoming lieutenant of the sixth his
zamboakto is called zabi maru and his
bankai is zusabi maro which is
translated to mean twin king snake or
simply two kings in the viz translation
now his bonkai was originally called
hikio zabimaru where his zombok toe
transformed into a large skeletal snake
that was like you know that of a whip he
had an ability called hikotsu taiho
where he could shoot large blasts of
concentrated spiritual energy at his
opponents he also had bonkai
reconstruction so segments of the snake
are held together with wrenchy's
spiritual power which will allow him to
separate and reattach the segments at
will now it was later revealed that this
was only half of rengi's banker's full
potential as his zombocto was holding
back some of its power until he was
ready ichibe hiusube revealed the true
name of renji's bankai to him which was
of course zu sabi maru on his left side
he has a baboon arm which is extremely
powerful powerful enough to crush the
bones of an opponent as well as being
able to throw around larger opponents
with ease and on the right side he had
his zompoc toe an ability he has is
called zusabi maro zagatepo which is
translated to mean two king snake tail
snake fang iron gun after renji has
impaled his enemy with the sword he will
then twist the sword as if he was
turning a key which forms the jaws of
spiritual energy the jaws then closed
down upon his enemy crushing them
completely with its fangs at the same
time wrenchy fires a blast of spiritual
energy through his enemy
it's a truly awesome move it really is
sergey and komamura was the captain of
the seventh division his sampakto was
called tenken and his bonk eye was
kokojio tengen mu when translated this
means vidyara of kalasutra's heavenly
punishment or divine retribution black
ropes of ruination per the viz
translation when his bonkai is activated
a samurai looking giant is summoned it
is referred to as a bonkai of living
armour the giant itself stands at around
100 meters tall and it wields a blade
similar to that of komamura's
this giant cop is the exact movement of
komamura and due to its size its
strength is of course far greater than
that of komamuras himself allowing him
to deal an insane amount of damage to
his opponent the giant can also take
quite a hit itself and despite its
overwhelming size it is still incredibly
fast as it copies exactly what komamura
is doing if he was to heal himself the
giant would also heal meaning is also
one of the only bonkai that can heal
itself then there is kokujo tengenmio
dungai joe in this form the giant
completely sheds its armor exposing its
body that is made entirely of spiritual
power this form can only come to be if
komamura uses the humanization technique
and when in this form his bonkai is
pretty much invulnerable to any physical
damage
shinsui kuroku was the former captain of
the eighth division now the captain of
the first division his zompokto is
called carton kyokotsu and his bonkai is
katan kyokotsu koromatsu shinju which
translated means bonwa of heavenly
blooming madness withering pine lovers
suicide or flower crazed heaven bone
spirit withered pine love suicide
according to the viz translation shunswe
will only ever use his bankai as a very
last resort if none of his allies are
nearby he will use it so they do not get
caught in its effects when he releases
his bonkai an aura covers the area
around shun sui and the aura changes the
perception of a person surrounding
environment who is caught within its
range everything becomes dark and gloomy
causing them to feel despair and sadness
shoon sweet's bonkai and its aura change
playing out the acts or dawns of a play
it's similar to rose's bonkai that we
talked about earlier in the video
however instead of only affecting their
senses or being an illusion shoon sui's
bonkai actually changes the battlefield
itself to suit his needs the first act
is hesitance and apportionment of wounds
where any wounds that either shun sweet
or his opponent inflict on the other's
body will occur to their own body as
well basically shared pain so shun sweet
says that this is the story of a man who
suffers from the same wounds as his
partner however he cannot die from them
the second act the pillow of shame makes
black spots appear all over his
opponent's body causing them to bleed
heavily the story continues here where
shoon sui says that this is the man of
the story feeling shame after wounding
his partner which caused him to collapse
and become very very ill the third act
is the severing abyss where a huge
amount of water engulfs both shunswe and
his opponent this water remains on the
battlefield until either he or his
opponent run out of spiritual energy and
drowns continuing shoonswee's story he
says that this part of the story is
where the two characters both hurl
themselves into the rushing waters the
final act thread cutting scissors upon a
blood streaked throat is where shoon
sweet sheaths both of his swords and
wraps a white thread around his
opponent's throat before pulling it
tight enough to leave a deep cup blowing
up their head completely pretty nasty
right
this act completes the story where he
says that the regretful man's partner
ignores his pleas and without mercy cuts
their throat his bonkai is definitely a
lot darker than you would have thought
huh
kensei mugaruma is the captain of the
ninth division and is also advised his
zompocto is called touchakaze and his
bonkai is tekken tachikaze which is
translated to mean iron fist severing
wind or according to the viz translation
iron fist earth severing wind upon his
bankai's activation a large explosion of
wind engulfs him after its disperse
tachikaze is transformed from a knife to
a pair of large knuckle blades with
purple bandages wrapped around both of
his arms like a sort of armor there is
also a thicker purple band that wraps
around him over his head his bonkai's
ability focuses all of his shikai's
power into the two knuckle blades giving
mugaruma's punches insane destructive
force that he will continuously pummel
his opponent with and as long as that
knuckleblade is in contact with his
opponent a barrage of explosions will
continuously go off as well as his
destructive power muguruma can also
change the knuckle blades into brass
knuckles as well as spiked gauntlets
kaname tozen was the former captain of
the 9th division before he betrayed the
soul society alongside both sosuke eisen
and guin ichimaru kaname's zampakto is
called suzumushi and his bonkai is
suzumushi sushiki enma karogi which is
translated to mean cricket final form
devil cricket or this is translation
which was bell bug closing ceremony
filled cricket when kaname activates his
bonkai the ring on his katana begins to
spin as it spins it starts to release
spiritual energy the ring begins to spin
faster and faster and faster as it grows
in size and then splits into 10 separate
glowing rings of equal size that circle
around kaname with the slash of his
sword the rings disperse and create a
large circular perimeter and the ten
rings begin to form a black void that
will continue to grow in size until it
forms a large solid black dome within
this dome a vacuum is created that
completely nullifies the senses of sight
sound scent and spiritual energy the
only sense that remains is that of touch
allowing kaname to attack them with his
sealed zampac toe now the dome itself is
an extension of suzumushi which allows
tozen to wield the sealed zompot to
itself within the dome and the downside
or weakness i guess you could say to
this is that by touching suzumushi's
hilt you become immune to the dome's
effects the dome will also continue to
exist as long as kaname wishes or if he
becomes seriously injured
toshiro hitsugaya is the captain of the
10th division
his zompocto is called hyorin maru and
his bonkai is daigoran hiron maru which
is translated to mean maha padma ice
ring or grand crimson lotus ice ring
according to the viz translation when
his guy activates his bankai ice from
hyorin maru begins to flow into
hitsagaya on his right hand the ice
forms and encases his sword in ice and
forms a dragon's head the ice continues
to form two wings on his back and a long
tail then the ice continues down his
left arm where an ice claw engulfs his
hand and heats the guy's feet are also
encased in this eye similar to the claw
on his left hand all of these frozen
limbs are fully functional and can be
used as an extension of himself during
battle in some cases three purple
flowers of ice also appear floating
behind him each of them have four petals
these petals melt away as the battle
progresses and they are said to be a
somewhat timer of how long heat sagaya
can remain in his bankai form hitsugai
as bonkai is another one of those that
is an extension of his shikai heats
hitsugaya can freeze both objects and
surroundings however when his bonkai is
activated this is much stronger and the
range is of course greater now his guy
is also able to use a range of ice type
techniques histogaya has zanyo ningyo
lingering ice puppet where he can create
a large amount of ice that is shaped to
look exactly like him these ice replicas
are very lifelike enough so that they
even bleed he's a guy can also use his
wings as a shield where he will wrap
them around himself like a sphere to
protect himself from attacks he also has
bunkai regeneration where his boncai
will regenerate as long as there is
moisture or water in the air ryusenka or
dragon hail cross is an attack where he
will stab his opponent and a burst of
ice will appear encasing his opponent
hitsugaya will then shatter that ice
with his target trap within it he also
has senen hyoyo thousand years ice
prison he's gaia will create loads of
ice pillars which circle around both
himself and his opponent when he
commands it these pillars will begin to
move towards his enemy crushing them
entirely guncho's serrara icicle flock
is where hitsugaya will freeze water
into ice and by swinging his zampakto in
an arc-like motion daggers of ice will
propel towards his target hyoyu sembi
ice dragon swelling tail is a swinging
motion from heater guys zampac toe that
creates an ice blade that shoots towards
his enemy he also has zeku or void sever
which allows his gaia to control this
technique further even sending the ice
blade into the air he's a guy's most
powerful technique is called hyoton
kyokasu frozen heaven hundred flower
funeral this is an ability that is an
extension of his tenso during power
where he can manipulate the weather be
it rain snow and ice at will with hyoton
kyokasu a huge hole opens in the clouds
and snow starts to fall when the
snowflakes make contact with his
opponent they create ice flowers that
appear all over their body that will
instantly trap them in a huge pillar of
ice now after the battle with eisen
hezekiah strengthened his bankai through
18 months of training into its completed
form he himself claimed that his body
wasn't mature enough at the time to
completely control his bonkai and to use
it to its fullest potential but after
reaching a more adult-like body he has
achieved this
kampachi zaraki is the current captain
of the infamous 11th division and is
also the 11th kenpachi to hold the
position his zampokto is called
nozarashi and was the only captain in
the history of the 13 court guard squads
to achieve the rank of captain without
knowing the name of his zampokto and
couldn't perform either of its release
states now it wasn't until he was beaten
by ichigo that he wanted to get stronger
later gaining the name of his zompoc toe
and achieving its released states the
name of kenpachi's bonkai is currently
unknown but we do know what it does so
when activated a huge level of energy is
released an energy so powerful that it
will take out buildings in the
surrounding area kempachi himself
changes his skin turns red and gains
black markings over his face as well as
gaining the addition of horns his
zampokto also undergoes a change looking
like an alternate version of the shikai
state this is also the only bonkai we
know of that actually changes the wilder
not only physically but their mental and
personality state too in this form
kenpachi is like a demon berserker who
gains an incredible amount of strength
and power he acts in a pure fit of rage
he is almost completely consumed
mindless and acts without regard for his
own life
ikaku madarame is the lieutenant of the
11th division formerly the third seat of
that same division his zampokto is
called hazukimaru and his bankai is
ryoman hizukimaru his bog kai looks
amazing in my opinion and is definitely
one of my favorites aesthetically so he
takes three segments of his shiikai and
turns them into three giant blades he
holds one of them in each hand and a
third axe blade floats behind him his
bonkai is basically a huge power up
however it doesn't offer any special
abilities or any defensive capabilities
now his bonkai does get stronger the
longer a fight drags on and once
activated ikaku's spiritual power raises
which is represented by a dragon crest
on the floating blade as the fight
progresses that dragon begins to fill up
kind of like a power-up bar in a game
and once this is full ryoman hazukimaru
is at its full power and that opponent
is truly in trouble ikaku himself has
said that his zampogto is very lazy and
battle and needs to be woken up either
through causing or receiving injury
maiori korotsuchi is the captain of the
12th division and is also the second
president of the shinigami research
institute he was formerly the third sea
of the twelve division under kisuke or
ahara mayuri's zompokto is called
ashisogi jizo and his bankai is kanji
ashisoki jizo translated as golden leg
cutting jizo or the viz translation of
divine leg cutting jizo now when his
bonkai is activated a giant monster
looking creature appears that has the
body of a caterpillar and a huge creepy
baby head wearing a red cape with baby
arms and a halo hovering above its head
the creepy baby creature breathes a
poison copy of mayuri's own blood that
is deadly to anyone who breathes it in
apart from mayuri himself and nemu this
poison can spread through an area of
around 200 meters and is almost
impossible to evade now there is an
antidote to this poison but it is kept
by both himself and nemu now due to the
fact that mayuri is a scientist and he
has modified his own bonkai in numerous
ways this is probably one of the most
versatile along with bjorkya's he has
rigged his bankai to self-destruct and
returned to its sealed state if it were
to attack him his bonkai also has
retractable blades that shoot out from
its chest that will completely skewer
his enemies this can also be combined
with its poison for an even more deadly
effect right he modified his bankai to
bear with me here but kanji ashishi jizu
matai fukuin shotai which this is
translated to simply demonic recumbent
womb this form is that of a giant purple
skinned baby wearing a golden loincloth
again it continues to just be gross but
it gets worse so said purple baby has a
giant gash on its belly with the kanji
conceal written on it and it is also
resting on a large pile of umbilical
cords
bruh anyway this creepy creature can
create modified versions of kanji
oshisogi jizo that have the information
or data that myori had sent to it that
copies the abilities of the ones who
have attacked it so let's 100 percent
move on from this insanity i just i
can't anymore it's so creepy it's it's
the worst but it's awesome the power's
awesome but the debate it just looks
creepy
kisuke urahara was the former captain of
the 12th division and was also the
founder and first president of the
shinigami research and development
institute his zombocto is called
benehime and his bonkai is canon biraki
benehime aratame which when translated
means modification of the crimson
princess's dissection at the doors of
avalokitsavara
definitely butchered that one this
helped us out here by translating it as
simply open red princess neo
i'm down with that anyway when activated
urahara's bankai takes the form of a
giant woman with dark braided hair with
mannequin-esque arms wearing a red robe
that stands behind him urohara keeps the
sealed sword for using kamba his bankai
has the ability to completely
restructure anything that it touches
offensively this can be used to split or
dissect something and for support it can
enhance things to bring them to their
optimal working state and beyond urohara
himself reconstructed his arm to have
greater strength against asking to
completely overwhelm him it can even
stitch things back together that were
once broken which i guess you could say
is a form of healing we saw urohara
restore his own eyes using this power to
restore his vision against again asking
that's just how insane the power of his
bankai's reconstructing ability truly is
now remember kisuke achieved his bankai
the same way as ichigo did by using the
ten shintai and learned bankai in just
three days
rukia kuchki is the current captain of
the 13th division where she formally
served as a lieutenant under giushiro
ukitake
herzompakto is called
sodnoshiroyuki and her bankai is haka no
tagame which is translated to mean
censure of the white haze or white haze
punishment under viz's translation when
activated her bankai changes her look
and attire completely now i honestly
really love the look of this and i guess
it gives us viewers an extra noise to
the already noise of rookia right
simping aside she is wearing a beautiful
white kimono with lined patterns it has
an extended collar with wider sleeves as
well as long flowing ribbons to finish
off that really majestic look rukia
herself has a small ice flower on the
center of her chest and a half crown her
hair also goes from that jet black
colour to a brilliant white and her
zompoc toe becomes transparent just as
ice so yeah hurt bonkai is an ice type
just as he's a guy is rukia can turn the
temperature to absolute zero within her
area of influence a pillar of absolute
cold mist rises way up into the air and
anything that is close to her becomes
frozen to the very core in an instant
said targets that become frozen begin to
crumble away in seconds and anyone who
makes contact with rukia while her
bankai is active begins to freeze
instantly
ichibai hyosube is the leader of the
zero division who also holds the title
monk who calls the real name his zambok
toe is called ichimonji and his bankai
is shirafude ichimonji which translated
means white brush straight line or there
is the viz translation of white brush
one written character now instead of
calling out bonkai to activate it like
all the others do ichibei calls ao
shinuchi which means true blade this is
because his zampogto ichimonji was the
first zompakto to take an evolved form
long before the term bonkai even existed
when activated the blade of his zampoc
toe takes on the form of a white brush
ichibe can give or change the name of a
target that is struck by the ink of his
zompoc toe by writing kanji on their
body by doing this he can change that
person's power so basically whatever he
decides to write on a person they become
as strong as that thing he wrote black
ant on yahwah and he became as weak as
that of a black ant all the strength
power and abilities he once had were now
reduced to that of a small insect
right then we are on to our final bonkai
and that is the bunk eye
of zorro just kidding our curiosity
though what kind of bonkai would zorro
have if he achieved it i'd be super
curious to know and uh yeah just let me
know what you think let us know in the
comment section below that'd be
interesting what what bonkai would zorro
from one piece of but yeah that is it
every bankai from bleach explained now
we really hope that you enjoyed today's
video and make sure to let us know in
the comment section below one what was
your favorite bonkai from bleach and two
would you like to see more bleach
content here on anime uproar if so what
characters and topics would you like to
see us cover as always if you enjoyed
this video and you'd like to see more
bleach videos on the channel make sure
to let us know by smashing that like
button get sugar 10 show style if you
haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future anime overall videos
remember you can also follow us on
twitter and instagram at anime or brawl
thanks again and we can't wait to see
you in the next one till next time peace